and we would live the years together
[Music]
Susan Boyle makes a surprise appearance
during the Britain's Got Talent finale
on Sunday and revealed she suffered a
stroke last year that left her without
her speech I thought that crazy to go
back on stage and I have done it the
Scottish singer took the stage with the
West End cast of Les Miserables to sing
I Dreamed a Dream the song she famously
sang when she was a contestant on the
show in 2009
[Music]
For What It Seems
[Applause]
everybody has a dream a sort of goal in
life the hope I can make other people
happy by being the professional singer I
want to be
[Music]
[Applause]
and when Susan was asked by the show's
host how she felt returning to the bgt
stage she shared some personal news
about her health I think she's specials
in the Ashley because and last Staples
I made a stroke and I thought that crazy
to go back on stage and I have done it
the show's Creator and judge Simon
Cowell was overjoyed to have Susan back
Susan we owe you so much and uh you know
I I knew you weren't well but if anyone
was going to come back you were going to
come back because we wouldn't be the
same without you of course back in 2009
when Susan first auditioned for the show
Simon was blown away by her Talent she
said I knew the minute you walked out
on that stage we were gonna hear
something extraordinary and I was right
and Piers Morgan who was a judge at the
time also praised her without a doubt
that was the biggest surprise I have had
in three years
so that was stunning an incredible
performance
of course Susan competed on the third
season of Britain's Got Talent where she
came in second place you said to me that
you came runner up to it to very
deserved winners do you feel it I really
do they're very entertaining and lots of
a show the best I'd like to think I can
improve and make myself better
we'll strive to do that and while she
may not have won Susan went on to have a
successful solo career her 2009 debut
album I Dreamed a Dream became the UK's
best-selling debut album of all time
that seems to have blown up
other proportion is just
unbelievable it's fantastic and on
Sunday night the wild horses singer
reflected on her return to the Show and
her health struggles on social media
saying it was a privilege for the past
year I have worked so hard to get my
speech and singing back with the sole
aim of being able to sing on stage again
Susan added that her hard work and
perseverance paid off and she was able
to sing the song that started it all
around the dreams
[Applause]